foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a special someone on the line
who's the special someone actor director
film Tom Brady no better than Tom Brady
better than showing Peyton even going to
my Broncos
star of so many things including
Breaking Bad Malcolm in the Middle up
for all kinds of awards Broadway he does
it all Brian Cranston that's the
gentleman oh all right
you you you're sending me into
retirement
you're announcing your retirement okay
wow this is this is a bad to do that
Brian
good
I'm I'm going to take my talent
Southwest and sit on a porch
uh what's going on
hey man uh thanks for taking my call I
was just listening to the show uh boy
Brady announces again uh Sean Payton
going to Denver I love it I know Sean a
little bit he's going to turn that
franchise around I really believe it
okay
and I really think so yeah
um is that why you called
no no
you're a Rams guy aren't you
I am a Rams guy I am and you know uh
last year the NFL asked me to do a
narration on the Rams season and their
ultimate uh Super Bowl victory and so I
was very proud to be able to lend my my
voice to the to the film and and I think
it was my narration of that film that
put the Rams in the position to repeat
well you did a great job I'd like to
hear you voice the Rams you know
seasonal recap this year
well it's a short recap yeah
oh my gosh yeah the wheels fell off uh
but you know I mean it's all about
regrouping isn't it they have to have to
do their job are you going to the Super
Bowl this year
I am uh uh I have announcement uh Aaron
Paul and I
are reprising our roles in Breaking Bad
for a Super Bowl commercial for pop
corners it's so much fun all right we we
had a blast doing this okay and uh Vince
Gilligan the guy who created Breaking
Bad directed it oh boy so we have a it's
a lot of fun you know doing seven years
of that show we didn't have a chance
very often to just cut up and have a lot
of fun and so getting that is getting a
lot of crew Back Together We shot this
commercial for PopCorners and we just
had a blast anyway so I'm going to I'm
going to uh Phoenix for the game but
what I realized is that when I did the
NFL narration
um part of the deal was that the NFL
supplied two tickets to the game well
those two tickets are now in excess of
what I have so I came up with this idea
to donate the tickets to a raffle
everything benefits big brothers and big
sisters of America and it includes these
two tickets to the Super Bowl airfare
hotel transportation and I'm gonna
rendezvous with the winner and you can
meet me
um and all you have to do
to support it is make a donation to do
big brothers and big sisters of America
go to Brian Cranston big game.com
and make a donation all it costs is five
bucks
and put yourself in the running we're
going to have the drawing on uh
Wednesday the 8th one week from today
awesome um so I'm hoping everybody can
get involved and uh you may be going to
the Super Bowl okay once again uh Brian
Cranston big game.com I have that right
that's correct all right it cost you
five bucks Everything 100 of the
proceeds goes to Big Brothers Big
Sisters of America and you get to meet
uh Brian Cranston you won't be in Walter
White character right that you're just
going to be Brian Cranston for the meet
and greet
I don't know I haven't decided yet you
know I'm that Walter White may have been
retired he's going he's got next to
um Brady on the porch
uh that's awesome uh will you keep us up
to date on this can we get updates from
you and uh yeah listen I'd love to come
back on the show and if we can I'd love
to be able to do the drawing on your
show can we arrange that for a week from
today I'll be able to do the drawing and
I can announce the person who's going
two tickets airfare hotel transpo it's
the whole thing and every single dollar
goes to big brothers and big sisters of
America and it's awesome all right
um fritzy you'll get all the information
from Brian and then we'll we'll have him
back and absolutely we'll make the
drawing next Wednesday uh hey Brian
great to talk to you we look forward to
seeing you in Arizona
thanks guys talk to you soon that's
Brian Cranston wow yeah a nice little
surprise there
he called him he called on a normal line
I know like that like Percy usually
gives the celebrities a hotline yeah
Brian in Los Angeles yeah